en berlín esta iglesia se ha convertido
en un banco de alimentos los refugiados
ucranianos vienen a recoger lo necesario
para su sustento básico una valiosa
ayuda para estos civiles que tuvieron
que huir de su país en berlín en berlín
nuestra familia está bien que tenemos
calefacción y agua caliente
pero la situación sigue siendo precaria
para los refugiados estos voluntarios de
una organización benéfica se encargan de
los alimentos las medicinas y otros
artículos de primera necesidad temen no
poder atender la demanda ante la
afluencia de refugiados ucranianos
pienso que veremos cómo se desarrollan
las cosas no somos un supermercado cada
semana podemos ofrecer lo que recibimos
y eso no está mal distribuiremos la
comida lo mejor posible para que todos
tengan algo
trasladarse a alemania una cuestión de
supervivencia para ellos ahora tienen
que adaptarse a un nuevo entorno
especialmente los niños que constituyen
una gran proporción de los refugiados
los voluntarios organizan clases de
alemán quieren ayudar a los más pequeños
a integrarse en el sistema escolar del
país
pero esta mujer
creo que es muy importante aprender
alemán quiero aprender
alemania pide un reparto más justo de
los refugiados ucranianos en la unión
europea según naciones unidas más de
cuatro millones de personas han huido de
ucrania desde que comenzó la guerra la
mayor crisis migratoria en europa desde
el final de la segunda guerra mundial